وفي تركيا ايضا نجحت حمله تبرعات في جمع
اكثر من 115 مليار ليره تعادل حوالي سته
مليارات ومئه مليون دولار لصالح المتضررين
من الزلزال وذكرت وكاله انباء الاناضول
التركيه ان 775 محطه تلفزيونيه واذاعيه في
تركيا واذربيجانه وقبرص التركيه بثت حمله
مشتركه لجمع التبرعات على مدار سبع ساعات
من البث المباشر وفي اتصال مع القنوات
المشاركه في الحمله التي اطلق عليها تركيا
قلب واحد اعلن محافظ البنك المركزي التركي
شهاب قوملو ان البنك سيتبرع ب 30 مليار
ليره تعادل حوالي مليار وستمائه مليون
دولار ويعادل مبلغ ربع الاموال التي جمعت
خلال الحمله كما تبرعت شركات كبرى ومصارف
حيث تبرع بنك زراعه الحكومي اكبر مصرف
تركي من حيث حجم الاصول بما يعادل حوالي
المليار دولار وشملت قائمه المتبرعين
شركتيل
الاتصالات والخطوط الجويه التركيه
بالاضافه الى بورصه اسطنبول
هذا وقال مصدر بالبنك المركزي التركي ان
تبرعات البنك التي تبلغ 30 مليار ليره اي
ما يعادل حوالي مليار و600 مليون دولار
للمناطق المتضرره من زلزال سوف تدفع من
ارباح البنك العام الماضي ويحول البنك
المركزي وارباحه عن العام السابق الى
الخزانه العامه في شهر ابريل نيسان من كل
عام لم يعلن البنك بعد عن ارباحه السنويه
لكن يتوقع ان تتجاوز المليارين ونصف
المليار دولار